in the beginning when i opened my first
store in venice i had no money at that
point so i literally put my personal
stuff on the walls my personal record
collection my personal skateboards and i
painted everything myself because i had
no budget for that so i don't know it's
just this whole kind of part of the
brand and my passion and the lifestyle
that i think you know leaves people
feeling good
i'm paige maikoski i'm the founder and
president of aviator nation
aviator nation is a lifestyle brand that
ultimately was created to bring people
together and
make quality clothing in america that
makes you feel comfortable and good
about yourself
fashion is honestly probably one of the
most competitive businesses out there i
think for me the made in america thing
is a huge part of that because
most companies even the companies that
start out with made in america end up
taking it overseas and now that i've
done this for 16 years and i'm still
making it in california where it's very
expensive obviously to make clothes you
know i think that that makes me feel
like i'm doing something different and
better
than a lot of other companies
i was actually living in california and
i was working in a surf shop and i was
doing photography freelance i thought
photography was my path but it was when
i was working in the surf shop and i was
around
clothing all the time that i realized i
had such a crazy passion
for the clothing and i would look at
clothes and be like i like that but i
want it to be this color i wanted to
have a different design and i just
became kind of obsessed with it and so i
bought a sewing machine and just started
making clothes for myself and i would
stay up late at night after work and
literally sew for hours trying to get
the fit right and the design right
and it wasn't just a fun little hobby it
was truly a passion and i became kind of
obsessed with it
once i had it to where i thought it was
perfect then i started
selling it at a street festival and so
that first time that i sold it at the
festival i think i paid like 500 for the
booth and i ended up making 8 000
in one day at a street fair so
pretty much immediately i was like i
need to quit my job at the surf shop and
just focus on this if i can make eight
thousand dollars in one day
there's a business here
fred seagull was the store in santa
monica that really took a chance on new
designers and so one day i rolled in
like my rack of clothes that i had
literally sewn in my garage and the the
buyer was blown away she was like i love
this it's amazing she bought everything
and she placed an order for close to
nine grand then literally one weekend
went by she called me on monday morning
and she said paige everything sold out
we need more we need to figure this out
like we need regular deliveries i
immediately went downtown and i went
door-to-door in factories starting to
look for sewers and build my team
in the beginning having no experience
and no formal training and just kind of
doing it the way that i
made sense to me drawing it by hand you
know ended up going into the early
designs and people loved that about the
clothes they loved that it was a little
bit imperfect you know and it wasn't
computer generated graphics which is
pretty much what most people do my thing
was i really wanted the clothes to look
vintage the machines that we use for
screen printing are different than what
most people use so we don't use all the
fancy new techniques most companies
would send garments through a basic wash
process that you know takes like 20
minutes or something like that i mean
our stuff is in the wash for like an
hour and a half and that's what i'm
passionate about because i want it to
feel vintage when you're buying it
[Music]
when i decided to start opening more
stores i wanted to make sure that the
store was really you know it had posters
and memorabilia and stuff from the
actual community so for example we're
here on the austin store there's a lot
of albums of artists that are from here
there's posters of willie nelson and
jason confused these are like iconic
figures that came from texas it
definitely makes each store super unique
and special to the community that it's
in
watching other companies and watching
the quality kind of go backwards i think
i always you know told myself i never
want that to happen i want our quality
to just get better there's corners you
can cut every day to make a lot more
money but if you're focused on the
quality like the customers are going to
stay and they're going to grow and
they're going to tell their friends and
that's what ultimately really makes us
successful
the reality is as an entrepreneur what
you start is about to become your entire
life so if you don't love it
this is going to suck for you you know
what i mean so like start with what you
love to do and then try to make that
your business because it's going to be
your life and then the money and all
that just comes because if you're doing
what you love people see that and they
want to be part of that the money will
come forget about the money
[Music]